♪♪
-Hey, everybody.
Welcome to another episode
of "Summer Corrections."
Or, as we've taken to
calling it, "Summerections."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause we love -- we love --
As we've established,
we love a portmanteau here.
[ Laughter ]
I will say...
I do find...
corrections
a little bit easier
the rest of the year,
for whatever it's worth.
I don't know
the difference, but...
Summerections are hard.
[ Laughter ]
So, I did -- since we missed
"Corrections" last week,
I missed Wednesday, Thursday
of last week
and Monday, Tuesday this week
because I tested positive
for COVID
last Wednesday morning.
And then, but I wanted
to come back.
I wanted to do
the two shows this week.
I'm very happy that we did.
I wanted to make sure that
it was safe before I came back.
So I went to the CDC website,
and I don't know if you've gone
and checked it recently,
but it just said,
"Ehh, do whatever you want."
[ Laughter ]
"You're not gonna listen.
Just do whatever you want."
"You don't have an aunt
who's been googling
you can check with?"
Oh, this is interesting.
We talked about Mac Tonight.
We've been talking
a little bit about Mac Tonight.
This was
a commercial spokesperson
that was launched in 1987
because McDonald's wanted kids
to have more nightmares.
[ Laughter ]
And I guess the idea was that
it was this...
you know, the kids
would just be terrified.
He had a piano.
The keys were made
from the bones of his victims.
And it would just,
kids would be terrified
and then they would wake up
and they'd be super upset
if they had seen Mac Tonight
and then the only way to get
them to calm down
was to go to McDonald's.
Anyway, this is fascinating.
This is not a correction.
This is just, again,
because I think at the end
we're trying to learn
with "Corrections," right?
I mean, that's what we've said.
Mac Tonight wasn't just like
a guy with a moon head on.
He was a fantastic actor
named Doug Jones.
Doug Jones was
in "Shape of Water."
This is the same actor.
He was in "Pan's Labyrinth."
He played the faun.
And so, he's this
wonderful actor, and this --
he got his start as Mac Tonight,
which is really cool.
So, and this is
the really amazing thing, right?
So, first he was Mac Tonight.
Then he was in "Shape of Water."
In "The Shape of Water,"
the character
in "Shape of Water" --
I don't know if you remember
this -- but ended up
as that.
[ Laughter ]
Full circle.
This one I feel terrible about.
We said that Rudy Giuliani
played "Wonderful Tonight"
at his first wedding when
he married his second cousin.
That song came out in 1977.
The wedding was 1968.
So, apologies to Rudy,
as well as to the daughter
of his first cousin.
[ Laughter ]
And I didn't know
how long ago that was
when Rudy married his cousin,
because 1968
was a different time.
Still weird
to marry your cousin.
I meant to say that that
an image was Photoshop friendly,
but I said it was
friendly Photoshop.
Me just ad-libbing, and
sometimes I say things wrong.
Also, that's just an age thing.
'Cause when we grew up,
Shoemaker and I,
when we grew up, like,
Photoshop wasn't a thing
you would do on your computer.
You would go to your friendly
neighborhood Photoshop.
[ Laughter ]
And do it all by hand.
You wouldn't just, like,
email Tara and say,
"Do this, make this image."
You would have to, like,
go down to the shop.
Carson, Johnny Carson,
would do it all the time.
He'd have to go to Burbank.
[ Laughter ]
"Can you, uh,
put Richard Nixon
in a prison uniform for me?"
And they'd be like, "When do you
need it by, Mr. Carson?"
He's like, "I'd love it
for tonight's show."
"It's gonna be --
it'll be weeks.
It's gonna take weeks."
One of you said...
Did a joke about Donald Trump
getting an ice cream headache
from a Frosty at Wendy's.
And you said you can't get
an ice cream headache
from a Frosty.
You can only get an ice cream
headache from an ice cream.
So, if you're drinking a Frosty
and you say to a friend,
"I have an ice cream headache,"
and that friend is a jackal,
they'll say to you,
"What'd ya get it from?"
[ Laughter ]
Oh, we were talking
about "Avatar."
It took six years in the film,
almost six years
to get to Pandora from Earth.
So, that means you could
go to Pandora and back
before "Avatar Two" came out.
[ Laughter ]
I do like to point out
when a jackal
writes something
that makes me smile.
And you said,
in James Cameron's defense,
the reason "Avatar Two"
is taking so long
is they're filming it
on location.
[ Laughter ]
I made a joke
in the last "Corrections"
where the punchline was
Kelly Rowland.
A lot of you didn't get it.
I think just go back
and watch it again.
[ Laughter ]
I could explain it,
but I just feel like
it wouldn't be as satisfying.
Hey, this isn't gonna be --
I should note,
this is not gonna be
a particularly
long "Corrections" tonight.
But I do want to address...
the Emmys.
The Emmys are coming up,
and "Corrections,"
as we know by now,
is Emmy-nominated.
But I was thinking about
Emmy categories that I wish --
when I had COVID
I watched a lot of TV --
Emmy categories
that I wish existed.
And here is an Emmy category
I wish existed.
It's the best line reading
on television this year.
It's the best pronunciation.
Let me specify
the best pronunciation of a word
that I had never heard
pronounced that way
on TV this year.
And the nominees are both
from "White Lotus."
The first nominee
is Molly Shannon
for the way she says
"palm fronds" in "White Lotus."
Take a look.
-[ Sighs ]
And all the palm fronds.
-Very good.
But what about
how Jennifer Coolidge
says "chaise lounge"
in "White Lotus?"
Let's take a look.
-That chaise is taken.
[ Laughter ]
-Impossible to choose.
In our category,
"Corrections'" category...
I promised I wouldn't
politic too much, but...
It's us, "Tooning Out the News,"
Stephen Colbert,
"Carpool Karaoke,"
"Randy Rainbow,"
and "I think You Should Leave
with Tim Robinson."
And, pains me to say it...
If you're wondering
who I think the winner is...
to quote the great Bob Dylan,
"It's not me, lady."
It's Tim Robinson.
"I Think You Should Leave" is...
"Coffin Flop" alone.
It deserves the Emmy.
And if you haven't seen
"Coffin Flop,"
go on Netflix and watch
"Coffin Flop."
And, look,
I aspire for excellence
and I would -- I would love
to win an Emmy.
But sometimes you have to say,
you know...
tied for second.
Hey, we're gonna be off
for all of August.
This is not our fault.
It's the fault of, really,
the summer TV viewer,
who doesn't enjoy watching
television in the summer.
And NBC executives
took us aside and said,
"You know what people
want in the summer?
It's, like, more like
'FBOY Island'
and less like your show."
And -- And we said,
"What if we made our show
a little bit more like
'FBOY Island'?"
And they said, "Well,
what's the closest thing
you have to an F-boy?"
And we said, "Scollins?"
And they said,
"Take off August."
[ Laughter ]
There's a conclusion of sorts
to the mug saga, you guys.
You know, we...
When we first came up
with this idea,
the question was,
how hard is it to make a mug?
And the answer is,
"Remarkably."
[ Laughter ]
But after a lot of work,
this is -- you guys,
this is now available
in the NBC Store.
It's the Late night
with Corrections Jackals mug.
And there's a jackal over here.
But there was a bit of drama,
you guys, with the mug.
So, here's what happened.
We were gonna announce the mug
two "Corrections" ago
and then, last minute,
I mentioned this on
on that "Corrections."
Actually,
it was one "Corrections,"
but two weeks ago.
It was like, "Whoa, it's not
in the store yet.
Don't announce it."
So I didn't announce it.
The last thing we want to do
is for you guys to,
you know, clog up the internet
trying to buy these
and they're not available yet.
So we didn't announce it.
Then, obviously, I have COVID.
In that time, though,
a really weird thing happened.
They started selling
a different "Corrections" mug
at the NBC Store.
It looked like this.
There were actually two of them,
and that was at the NBC Store.
And so we were shocked
because we've had
a lot of conversations
about the mug
and all of a sudden a mug
that I've never seen before
was in the NBC Store.
And our producer,
Eric Leiderman,
he wrote me an email
about what had happened,
and I was gonna read it to you.
But I'm not going to,
because here's the thing.
I'm not saying it's long...
[ Laughter ]
But if I read you
the full email,
we would all miss
the premiere
of "Avatar Three."
[ Laughter ]
The thing is, I feel terrible,
but if you bought this mug,
this is not an official
"Corrections" mug.
You have -- I mean,
you have a mug, and it's --
look, it says
"Corrections Jackal"
and I hope you enjoy it,
but it's a little bit
like, you know, you think
you bought a Chanel bag
and you get home and your
friend's like,
"That says Channel."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you know...
I was looking on Etsy.
Some people on Etsy
have just been making
their own "Corrections" mugs.
That one's nice.
Got an Egyptian theme to it.
This one's nice.
So, I think
the important thing to note
is this is...
this is our segment
that we do every week,
and when it came
to making the mugs,
we finished last.
[ Laughter ]
[ Clears throat ]
But, you know,
I think in the end, any --
I think any mug
you want to buy for yourself
that you think best represents
the kind of jackal you are,
I think go for it,
because if we've learned
anything from this journey
of "Corrections,"
there are no right answers.
But it's here.
♪ Summer muggin' ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Happened so slow ♪
♪ Tell me less, tell me less ♪
[ Laughs ]
That's great, though.
We got our own mug.
Come on, back me up, guys.
This is really nice.
I will say...
being right-handed,
I kind of prefer this side,
you know, and I was like,
as a righty,
the side I like less
is facing out.
So I said, "How hard
would it be...?"
28 months.
[ Laughter ]
So, I...
You know, I don't
want you to think --
'cause sometimes
you all say, "Hey..."
"Enjoying your summer vacation?"
No.
I like it here.
I like doing this.
I don't like being at the beach.
I'm not being lazy.
Okay?
But the important thing
is we were together today,
we'll be together again
in September.
Vote "I Think You Should
Leave with Tim Robinson."
Get whatever [bleep] mug
you want.
[ Laughter ]
You know what really bums me out
about these Etsy people...
...is their tiny little
pine cones.
[ Laughter ]
Like a couple of jackal's nuts.
[ Laughs ]
They're -- They're just so...
They're just so ahead of us.
And we're a major corporation.
It took us like a year
to make a mug.
Like this -- I want this mug
'cause I know, thanks to that,
I know exactly how big it is.
[ Laughter ]
You guys,
have a wonderful summer.
We love you very much.
See me in September.